a vlad also a missing teenager case that
had a miracle ending
this is a wonderful story so 18 year old
gia
fuda was missing for nine days in a
wooded area east of seattle before
she was found alive she was reunited
with her parents on saturday watch
they pulled up in that jeep and it was
holy cow
a miracle yeah there she was it was just
like unreal
shows that miracles do happen and don't
ever quit and that's what we're doing
they just continued to search and
thankfully found her
rescuers found gia next to a creek in a
steep ravine
in the cascade mountains she told her
parents her car ran out of gas
and she got lost looking for help she
has survived
on berries and creek water she suffered
only dehydration
and a few scratches miracles do happen
and never quit jeff i love
what the sheriff said there about never
quitting fact that she was able to
survive just on
what she found in the surrounding area
and of course on fresh water
what a story amazing not as miraculous
as eureka's toss
oh you got jokes today you got a whole
week left to do those erika